buongiorno a tutti io sono da
d'alessandro e solo imprenditore
da un'identità digitale da un brand
digitale il ragazzi ruolo creato otto
anni fa e da cui abbiamo appunto dal
brand creato ovviamente una identità
digitale e quindi costruendoci il nostro
pubblico e poi successivamente arrivando
a costruire una propria ed era attività
imprenditoriale
ovviamente all'inizio un'attività
imprenditoriale più piccola che poi si è
allargato nel tempo con vari
investimenti fatti soprattutto sul
fronte digitale oggi quello di cui io le
volevo parlare è appunto il tema di
questo sviluppo di questa identità
digitale partendo però da facendo
un'attività un po diversa cioè si la
creazione di un brand la creazione di un
marchio l'identificazione di un proprio
pubblico per poi successivamente
animarono attività imprenditoriale
parliamo che in realtà del ragazzo di
bollo da si parlò di un attimo dell'area
di questa storia è narrata di un'epoca
dove 8 7 8 anni fa a un'epoca dove
l'identità digitale era ovviamente
qualcosa di diverso da oggi
otto anni nel digitale cambiano
veramente tanto
ma noi comunque facciamo appunto
supporto alle delle nuove aziende che le
start up e quindi segnando tuttora i
processi
una delle cose che voglio dire perché
parma anche spesso alle scuole
soprattutto superiori è quello di avere
prima di tutto chiara la propria
il proprio core business la scuola è
stata la propria attività principale da
quello costruire un brand ma un brand
inteso non solo come marchio come
potremmo tradurlo in italiano marchio ma
come una serie di componenti che
costruiscono questo marchio quindi se lo
sostituisco un'attività imprenditoriale
anche di abbigliamento prendo ad esempio
l'abbigliamento che è un tema che sento
molto ricorrere uno abbastanza
ricorrente che nel nostro territorio
prima di tutto dovrò cercare di
costruire più che come farò i vestiti
che tipo di marche di abbigliamento sarò
ad esempio mi viene da dire sportivo
piuttosto che elegante questo permette
sicuramente di costruire un brand che
dovrà essere una fotocopia in tutti i
movimenti di quello che poi verrà fatto
ad oggi abilmente gli strumenti digitali
che abbiamo tutti i vari social sono
assolutamente importanti anche su questo
miglior esso fermare un attimo facendo
con un po con la distinzione ci sono ed
eros i tanti social network ma non tutti
sono giusti per tutti i tipi di attività
ne esistono veramente tantissimi quando
si parla e si dice faccio un esempio tik
tok adesso è sicuramente molto forte
certo ti toc è molto importante e va
analizzato però potrebbe non essere
adatto a un'azienda social meno
meno in auge in questo momento come può
essere twitter invece rivelarsi molto
utile per questo per il proprio tipo di
pubblico
quindi anche nella creazione del brand
capire anche dove far poi svolgere
l'attività digitale al proprio brand e
quindi non impuntarsi per forza con
instagram funziona di più di facebook mi
dà più visibilità
dipende che tipo di visibilità può
essere data miniere da fare un esempio
anche in questo caso se io devo vendere
un prodotto deciso di fare un prodotto
molto di nicchia sarà inutile che mi
metta in piazza maggiore con un megafono
mo ad urlare che vendo questo prodotto
comunicandolo a mille persone se magari
un prodotto d'elite
magari sarà meglio che le dica con un
tono normale a 10 persone in galleria
cavour perché di bologna quindi inteso
una zona dove di solito c'è un pubblico
più abbiente mentre su piazza maggiore
abbiamo invece un pubblico più generico
quindi anche canalizzarsi meglio sul
tipo di pubblico quindi ama parlare
quindi non sempre tanto e bene
nella costruzione di quindi di questo di
questa di identità digitale capire dove
lo si utilizzerà cioè dove si faranno la
maggior parte del lavoro è abbastanza
importante quindi non per forza ripeto
il social nausee è quello che puoi
aiuterà ad andare
il brand arrivando poi alla parte del
brand
bisogna capire bene io qui non mi
mettono mi metto a parlare di grafica
tecnicamente ma proprio di costruzione
del brand cioè che cosa deve andare a
dire una persona molto spesso anche
l'utilizzo della lingua
usiamo molto spesso inglese ora molte
terminologie tecniche sono per forza in
inglese e questo all'obbligo però per
forza parlare l'inglese non è
obbligatorio noi con la nostra realtà
comunichiamo in dialetto
quindi forse un passo indietro a quello
che è lo standard di parlare in modo
universale perché perché dipende tutto
da chi mi rivolgo quindi il voler io
spesso vedo questa cosa dove molte
startup tendono a voler comunicare a
livelli molto alti con grandissime
terminologie straniere ad un pubblico
che nessuna gara ma il pubblico di
persone un po più anziane o comunque non
più giovanissime che magari tutte queste
termini leggi inglesi non le capiscono o
mi viene a pensare se si si si offrono
un prodotto a una piccola alla piccola e
media impresa ma non tutta la piccola
impresa alla bottega sotto casa non ha
senso rendere troppo complesso il
sistema comunicativo
anzi dovremmo snellirlo parlano
l'italiano assolutamente molto semplice
molto fruibile a tutti
sostanzialmente quindi non è che ci
rende più più bravi più capaci se
sappiamo parlare perfettamente inglese
con tutte le terminologie tecniche
ovviamente se ci poniamo realtà tecniche
professionali
ovvio che utilizzeremo quindi questi
questi terminologie e gli strumenti che
ci vengono dati però dobbiamo davvero
capire con chi comunicano io per esempio
che non sono un grande amante del
dell'utilizzo della comicità della carta
stampata ma non perché venite contro la
carta
stampata perché nelle attività che con
cui normalmente lavoro la carta stampata
non è il metodo comunicativo migliore
quindi è proprio un obbligo di lavoro e
verrà ci sono alcune attività rare ma ci
sono alcune attività per cui
l'investimento sulla carta stampata
ancora su vecchie caro giornale con una
frase scritta è ancora in un modo un po
pubblicitario un po vecchio può
funzionare assolutamente abbastanza bene
quindi quando progettiamo il nostro
brand è davvero molto importante capire
con chi comunichiamo noi per esempio che
comunichiamo quello pubblico molto
giovane non abbiamo mai deciso di
strutturare questo tipo di comunicazione
appunto in modo molto complesso ma anzi
tutt'altro deve essere quando cunico i
giovani deve essere molto breve
molto semplice e deve arrivare subito a
colpire l'interesse perché hai veramente
pochissime righe e pochissimo spazio
tutto questo discorso perché perché il
brand in realtà segue quello che poi noi
decidiamo di fare e con chi decidiamo di
farlo per questo tengo molto a punto
puntualizzarlo un attimo sul metodo
comunicativo
il brand dovrà riprodurre assolutamente
questo è anche l'identità digitale
quindi costruire un'identità digitale e
parliamo anche proprio delle grafiche
grafiche molto complesse piene di
particolari non sempre è così che si
riesce a far finire bene del contenuto
magari il contenuto minimalista ha
sicuramente una funzione che in alcuni
casi ha un riscontro molto più positivo
ecco diciamo che sostanzialmente avendo
poi su questo argomento bisognerebbe
parlare veramente per tantissimo tempo
però diciamo che per dare uno spunto
questo è secondo me inizio più
importante capire con chi comunicare e
non voler appesantire troppo il sistema
comunicativo e quindi il proprio brand
ma anzi tra le due renderlo più semplice
più facile e molto spesso anche più
locale se c'è bisogno
a meno che ovviamente non si voglia fare
una multinazionale
grazie a tutti per avermi ascoltato